welcome to Blackwood
Pharmaceuticals thank you for your
interest in our phase one clinical
trials Blackwood are committed to
innovation without your help none of
this would be
possible this is a double blind trial 5
days total what we're really interested
in now is how long you can stay away let
me guess heard a b from a friend thought
easy money right don't have a lot of
other options sir young broke and
desperate it's a drug Tri magic combo
now take a deep breath I need dizziness
no nausea no headache
no it's their own antibodies that are
causing the inflammation no
please please let me out their whole
immune systems have gone
haywi on this phone is the only true
record what happened
here security reach everyone stay awake
whatever you do don't go to sleep don't
even close your eyes if you fall asleep
you'll
die
hey
[Music]
a